Javier munos grew up in jerez he knows
all the wine cellars or bodyguards here
this is where sherry was invented more
than 200 years ago it's a dry white wine
made from Palomino grapes and fortified
with brandy which originally served to
preserve the wine during transport
abroad sherry is a blends of wines from
different years so as to guarantee a
uniform quality they range from the pale
dry fino to the strong dark order Oso
and the sweet Pedro Jimenez
a tobie know some unique o en el mundo
department these wines are unique in the
world that's mainly due to the
temperature which our labor goes below
zero Celsius and rarely exceeds 40
degrees per una temporada media simply
de vinter we usually have 20 to 25
degrees non-immigrant equally decade in
a leprosy the other factor is the
proximity to see Matt the wind brings in
a salty air that influences the Sherry's
aroma Laura Laura tomorrow
the sea and the nearby Sierra Nevada
mountains produce many of the
specialities on offer at the market in
jerez Javier munos gets much of his
inspiration here he belongs to a
generation of top young spanish chefs
who've already made a name for
themselves nationwide beyond their home
regions
yep no cake every product here can be
marinated or cooked with sherry
carbone our restaurant is located in a
former bodega and that suits have yet
more noses style of cooking nicely that
the bikini optic whether i can remember
the way it smelled out on the street
when I was little Easter for example
they say same band there was always this
ml of sherry and dr. quondam and I kept
our memory our lives and so I started
cooking but I could make it to vent
window for euromaxx Munoz is preparing a
traditional meat dish with vegetables
first he braises onions leeks and
carrots in olive oil for flavor he adds
some peppercorns and a sprig of rosemary
now he seasoned some calves cheeks with
salt and pepper after dredging them in
flour he fries them in oil to close the
pores in the meat the best part of a
liter of LR 0 so sherry is then poured
over the vegetables in a toga she owned
like to meet the hola Rosa was strong in
taste so it goes well with this deal
shape chemical a peculiar they'll be no
time in a company aryl platter now he
adds the meat and simmers everything for
four hours nothing home even if the pot
for pot roast you need to start with
enough liquid adding cold water later
you'll interrupt the cooking process
that makes the meat tough
the gravy starts with caramelized sugar
deglazed with a generous shot of sharing
the liquid from the meat is strained
into it through a sieve
we had flambé Aden the alcohol in the
ala Rosa boils off and you're left with
the sherry taste but no alcohol in the
dish put in her blood then it's time to
serve it a bed of mashed potatoes then
the meat topped with a garnish of
vegetables and the sauce and of course
what else a small glass of sherry is the
traditional accompaniment to this dish